His full name is Mymains Stewart Gilligan and we call him Stewie for short,...
...and yes, that does come from Family Guy.
When we first got him, Stewie was just an average - sized Maine Coon kitten.
There was no indication at all that he was going to be as large and as long...
...as he did end up doing after me.
When I take Stewie to the cat shows, normally the position that I carry him in,...
...when I take him to him from the cat show rings, is that stretched out position.
So people really get to see his length. And I've heard,...
..."Oh My God, that's the largest thing I've ever seen!"
Or basically I just get a lot of the,...
...you know, "Wow!" all of that good stuff.
About the 5000th time I heard somebody say, "He's got to be the longest cat I've ever seen",...
...we finally started looking at measuring him...
...to see if he could qualify as a Guinness World Record holder.
So, we watched him grow for a couple of years and throughout the record attempts,...
...and then finally when we got that, that last one, we were overjoyed.
Because we knew that it was over the previous Guinness World Record holder's measurement.